parler d'un autre aspect c'est que moi
j'aime beaucoup le côté bible de la
chanson française ait connu tout le
monde même dans les artistes votre
relation fraternelle avec patrick
sébastien tout ça moi ça me passionne
mais ce qui m'a passionné encore plus
c'est toutes les histoires de cul
raconter votre vécu on sait que dans
vécu ma vie et il ya aussi des romans
feuilletons pornographiques dans
lesquelles vous avez créé là aussi où ça
se passe là la qualification le pass
alors ça c'est pas du fait divers
acteurs du rosé de doux ton prono
surtout où sont ces housses on s'est
revus alors ça commence et et blanc
j'étais étudiant j'ai été étudiant à
l'époque puis tous mes copains de classe
et revues étudiante ça pour sortir
bayane acquise et du baby sitting ça
leur apporter 60 prendre l'eau dans
l'âme d'un week end qui tondait des
pelouses d'autres qui qui l avait des
voitures pour 10 francs et séraphin
francs bref moi je vais rencontrer le
secrétaire brigitte bardot qui est un
ancien a qui font roman photo mamy dans
un réseau comme ça pour gagner ma vie
les malfrats d'iodé parce que c'était du
roman-photo adulte quand ils ont
commencé à me demander des mensurations
pour tout le monde parce qu'à un moment
donné il m'a demandé des mensurations je
me dis tiens pour du roman photo mais
curieux si c'est pour faire nous deux
confidences de l'avs ai donné quelques
chiffres
[Rires]
allez répondre ce n'est pas tout une
fatigue des mémoires d'un âne ses
chaussures et donc j'ai commencé ça j'ai
passé des tests de bonne santé et c'est
être avais je suis parti en angleterre
tournée
alors c'était 15000 francs le samedi et
20000 quand on faisait le samedi et
dimanche
alors c'était compliqué que des ponts
peut pas faire deux jours il y avait
trop de travail
c'est très compliqué non c'est c'est un
énorme travail c'est plus difficile que
les films qu'est ce qu'on a compris qu
est ce qu on fige l'instant ce que l'on
fiche l'instant exactement redonner le
metteur en scène dit ils vivent plus je
me souvienne cette époque-là des romans
il y avait barbara cartland le club des
cinq et roman où il est tout à fait
comme ça des pauses tellement craintes
étaient vendus dans des sachets oui et
c'est une fois raconté sarah dessaint
pierre je crois parce que je les cache
et pas en traînant dans l'urgence en
effet les bouvard pourquoi des saveurs
dans les boutiques
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
donc en fait c'est bien le produit
voir les années chez lui des trucs à
d'abord c'est très difficile parce que
j'ai le premier jour c'était un test en
même temps et je me souviens on est en
peignoir et on est des bons il ya cinq
personnes autour de nous un et le viagra
même à présent il y en as historique
parce que à la corde et litterna ça
n'existe plus tout ça elle nous est
quand même unique
non mais on peut pas l'inventaire mais
bien son nom mais c'était c'était
incroyable parce que vous savez pour les
ardeurs sur les tournages mais pas comme
si les tarnais visuels destin avec votre
mère est alors les ardeurs ont la
particularité un orage vous le disent à
peu un peu chaud vous servir mais que
cet empire
je suis tout ouïe si un jour vous tombez
sur un mauvais coup ouais et bien faut
l'obliger à manger duzan vous le mettez
dans le bouquin est en partie ce que le
temps a une particularité d'augmenter la
tension artérielle et lâche t on
trouvait de tout jamais mangé de citron
la veille ah oui carrément
je me disais que si tu me regardes tu
sais pas bien parce que le citron et un
régulateur de tension
évidemment fait ce qu'ils ont dit père
tension prennent souvent des médicaments
à base de citron de l'outil tron ça fait
légèrement tombé à la tension artérielle
donc vous on appelle souvent des mousses
si on doit parler un langage technique
d'accord il précisait à tous ceux qui
prennent du cialis tu prends du temps en
plus c'est pas la peine mais avec bien
sûr mais est alors moi pour l'anecdote
la preuve le premier jour j'avais donc
pris du temps la veille mais faut pas le
prendre la veille passer ça l'aï joué
dans les trucs où tu vas il met en fête
les héros est passé des salariés c'est
fascinant mais on a plusieurs visages et
c'est ce que j'ai et en fait non mais ce
qui est ailleurs fou c'est que j'avais
pris le temps je suis pas moi la veille
ou vraiment le matin j'avais oublié ce
sens qu'ils recommandaient tout le monde
c'est un détail important mais qu'à son
rôle et moi j'avais la langue marron
avec le temps ça fait la langue marron
il faut ce qu'il faut
et donc est donc c'est terrible parce
que j'ai pas moyen qu'ils aient décliné
lundi son gros plan selon les plans ce
jour là non mais ce jour là j'étais au
chômage technique
parce qu'on ne peut pas faire tout ce
qui était gros plan est encore là parce
que j'ai eu beau me l'avait tout de
suite
on compte une voix arrivé comme ça tu
penses pas que c'est rocco siffredi ccg
jouer j'en ai fait 117 en fait 18 mois
mais ça va ça va vite parce que la
france ça va très vite en vue en photo
[Applaudissements]
faut dire que lui c'est pas bien je ne
sais c'est grisant et des petits
fascicules de passage mais il faut dire
qu'à la page 2 tout on est couché déjà
attribués et un dans le temps là le
scénario savamment texte